in this video we'll study the encoder
decoder architecture
an example of a popular encoder decoder
model
is t5 in order to understand how the
encoder decoder works we recommend you
check out the videos on encoders
and decoders as standalone models
understanding how they work individually
will help understanding how an encoder
decoder works
let's start from what we've seen about
the encoder the
encoder takes words as inputs casts them
through the encoder and retrieves a
numerical representation
for each word cast through it we now
know
that that this numerical representation
holds information about the meaning of
the sequence
let's put this aside and add the decoder
to the diagram
in this scenario we're using the decoder
in a manner that we haven't seen before
we're passing the outputs of the encoder
directly to it
additionally to the encoder output we
also give the decoder a sequence
when prompting their decoder for an
output with no initial sequence
we can give it the value that indicates
the start of a sequence
and that's where the encoder decoding
magic happens
the encoder accepts a sequence as input
it computes a prediction and outputs a
numerical representation
then it sends that over to the decoder
it has in a sense encoded that sequence
and the decoder in turn using this input
alongside its usual sequence input
will take a stab at decoding the
sequence
the decoder decodes the sequence and
outputs a word
as of now we don't really need to make
sense of that word but we can understand
that the decoder is essentially decoding
what the encoder has
output the start of sequence here
the start of sequence word here
indicates that it should start decoding
the sequence
now that we have both the encoder
numerical representation
and an initial generated word we don't
need the encoder anymore
as we have seen before with the decoder
it can act in an
autoregressive manner the word it has
just output can now be used as an
input this in combination with the
numerical representation
output by the encoder can now be used to
generate
a second word
please note that the first word is still
here as the model still outputs it
however we have graded out as we have no
need for it anymore
we can continue on and on for example
until the decoder outputs a value that
we consider a stopping value
like a dot meaning the end of a sequence
here we've seen the full mechanism of
the encoder decoder transformer
let's go over it one more time we have
an initial sequence that is sent to the
encoder
that encoder output is then sent to
their decoder for it to be decoded
while it can now discard the encoder
after a single use
the decoder will be used several times
until we have
generated every word that we need
so let's see a concrete example with
translation language modeling
also called transduction which is the
act of translating a sequence
here we would like to translate this
english sequence welcome to nyc in
french
we're using a transformer model that is
trained for that task
explicitly we use the encoder to create
a representation of the english sentence
we cast this to the decoder with the use
of the start of sequence word
we ask it to output the first word
it outputs b avenue which means welcome
and we then use bienvenue as the input
sequence for the decoder
this alongside the encoder numerical
representation
allows the decoder to predict the second
word ah which is two in english
finally we ask the decoder to predict a
third word
it predicts nyc which is correct we've
translated the
the sentence where the encoder decoder
really shines is that we have an encoder
and a decoder which often do not share
weights
therefore we have an entire block the
encoder that can be trained to
understand the sequence
and extract the relevant information for
the translation scenario we've seen
earlier for example this would mean
parsing and
understanding what was said in the
english language
it would mean extracting information
from that language
and putting putting all of that in a
vector dense information
on the other hand we have the decoder
whose sole purpose is to decode the
numerical representation
output by the encoder this decoder can
be specialized in a completely different
language
or even modality like images or speech
encoders decoders are special for
several reasons
firstly they are able they are able to
manage sequence to sequence tasks
like translation that we have just seen
secondly the ways between the encoder
and the decoder parts are not
necessarily shared
let's take another example of
translation
here where translating transformers are
powerful in french
firstly this means that from a sequence
of three words
we're able to generate a sequence of
four words
one could argue that this could be
handled with a decoder
that would generate the translation in
an auto-regressive manner
and they would be right
another example of where sequence to
sequence transformers shine is in
summarization
here we have very a very long sequence
generally a full text
and we want to summarize it since the
encoder and decoders are separated
we can have different context lengths
for example a very long context for the
encoder
which handles the text and a smaller
context for the decoder which handles
the summarized sequence
there are a lot of sequence to sequence
models this contains a few examples of
popular encoder decoder models available
in the transformers library
additionally you can load an encoder and
a decoder
inside an encoder decoder model
therefore according to the specific task
you're targeting
you may choose to use specific encoders
and decoders which have proven their
worth
on these specific tasks